تزايد الحديث في الاونه الاخيره عن السلام
ونهايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا بالطرق
الدبلوماسيه
تفاءل العالم وتنفس السعداء لكن مواقف
موسكو وكيف لا تزال متباعده رغم الاحاديث
المتكرره عن السلام التفاؤل الحذر بدده
المتحدث باسم الكرام لندن بالقول ان روسيا
لن تجري مفاوضات بناء على شروط الاخرين
ردا على تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا بشان عقد قمه سلام في فبراير
من العام المقبل بسكوف قال الصحفيين ان
روسيا كانت تنطلق دائما من شروطها
والتفكير السليم ردا على سؤال حول ما اذا
كانت موسكو مستعده للتفاوض بشروط اكياف
مناقضا حديث سيد الكرملين قبل ايام عن
استعداد موسكو للتفاوض الكلام لان كان يرد
تحديدا على تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني الذي اشار الى ان حكومته تهدف
الى عقد قمه السلام بحلول نهايه فبراير
المقبل
ان تكون في الامم المتحده بحضور الامين
العامه تونيغوث كوصيه المحتمل دي
متروكوليبا
نهدف الى قمه دوليه في نهايه فبراير عندما
تدخل الحرب عامها الثاني فكره صيغه السلام
ستكون ذات شقين اولها عدم السماح لروسيا
بالتلاعب بقضيه السلام لانهم يقولون
باستمرار انهم مستعدون للمفاوضات وهذا غير
صحيح لان كل ما يفعلونه في ساحه المعركه
يثبت العكس تماما اما الشوط الثاني هو
محاكمه روسيه عن جرائم الحرب
لكن وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه ذهبت بعيدا
عبر مطالبتها رسميا باستبعاد روسيا من
مقعدها الدائم في مجلس الامن الدولي وهو
مطلب لا فرص له بالنجاح حاليا مع تمتع
موسكو بحق النقد الفيتو الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ذكرت في بيان ان اوكرانيا تدعو
الدول الاعضاء في الامم المتحده الى حرمان
روسيا الاتحاديه من وضعها كعضو دائم في
مجلس الامن والاستبعادها كليا من الامم
المتحده كان كليب اشار الى ان مساله شغل
روسيا مقعدا دائما في مجلس الامن تناقشه
اساسا في الاوساط الدبلوماسيه وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني وبعدما اوضح ان هذه
المساله لم تطرح بعده في مؤتمرات صحفيه او
بيانات عامه لقاده الدول والحكومات قال
انه على مستوى ادناه يتم طرح السؤال
بالفعل حول ما يجب ان تصبح روسيا حتى لا
تشكل تهديدا للسلام والامن جانب اخر هام
جدا يقع في صلب اي عمليه او اتفاق سلام
متوقع بين موسكو وكياف التعويضات هل ستدفع
روسيا لجارتها الغربيه فاتوره الحرب وهل
يمكن اساسا اجبار موسكو على الدفع
يجب على روسيا ان تدفع ثمن تحقيق العداله
في نهايه المطاف تلك رؤيه ثابته في كاف
الطريقه او الطرق ربما ليست واضحه حتى
الان لكن الجمعيه العموميه للامم المتحده
اصدرت قرارا غير ملزما في ال 14 من نوفمبر
الماضي ده على روسيا الى دفع تعويضات فعلا
50 دوله في تقديم القرار المتعلق بانشائي
الي دوليا للتعويض عن الاضرار والخسائر
والاصابات فضلا عن سجل لتوفيق الادله
والمطالبات لكنه يبقى غير ملزم ويبقى لي
موسكو وبالتالي هذا يفسر دعوه كوليبا بعد
روسيا من الامم المتحده ومن مجلس الامن
تحديدا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
[موسيقى]